hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in part one of
the spoke is Arthur Stroh there's a
section called of the after worlds men
the people who are constantly striving
for and talking about and orienting
themselves in relation to some other
world than the one that we live in
experience things in they may talk about
an afterlife they may talk about some
ideal realm but they all have something
in common and this chapter begins in a
very interesting way with Zarathustra
Nietzsche's mouthpiece confessing that
he himself imagined a sort of projected
being that then would have created the
world and this bears resemblance to some
other religious and philosophical
conceptions that you can find he says
that Zarathustra cast his deluded fancy
beyond mankind like all after world's
minore or beyond world's men hinter
belts right and he said the world then
seemed to me like the work of a
suffering and tormented God so instead
of assuming a God who is perfect
totally unified all the attributes in
harmony with each other he assumed a
super powerful being
who's a suffering God and that suffering
God creates the world precisely in order
to distract himself or itself or
whatever it is from that suffering that
they're experiencing and the suffering
is caused since there's no world before
that by their own nature says the world
seemed to me the dream and fiction of
God colored vapor before the eyes of a
discontented God good evil joy sorrow I
you I thought all of them to be things
fabricated by this creature this Creator
the Creator wanted to look away from
himself so he creates the world and
thereby he has a spectacle that can
allow him to forget his suffering and
forget himself so he says intoxicating
joy and self forgetting this is what I
once thought the world now what would
that mean about this world this world
would not be some perfect realm in which
the Creator loses himself in esthetic
contemplation of beauty or anything like
that no the world that actually be more
screwed up than him the world would
offer its spectacle precisely because it
is a chaos because things you know war
against each other strive against each
other it would be as he says an
internally imperfect image of a
contradiction a beautiful phrase right
there it's not just saying that it's a
contradiction it's yet an image of a
contradiction and here we might think
that Nietzsche is in some respect
playing off of the Genesis account of
God creating man or humankind in his own
image right the world is created in the
image of a contradiction and in some
ways it's even more contradictory than
the contradiction in this this was crazy
God so he says this would be an
intoxicating joy to its imperfect
creator that is what I once thought the
world how did I get out of that
then I realized that this God that I
created was human work and human madness
like all other gods it's just something
that we're projecting beyond ourselves
and now we lead into a different
approach that human beings have taken
why would we come up with this God who
is Kenneth Nutty and creates a crappy
world well it explains the suffering
that we're in and you know in some way
redeems that suffering not by
transforming it into something else but
allowing us the distraction perhaps
humor perhaps irony something else but
there's a lot of people who are deadly
serious about this and they project an
afterlife an eternal world a god
whatever it is that you're going to say
comes next
couldn't even be you know Nirvana or you
know the endless cycle of birth and
rebirth all of these things are being
projected as ways to deal with the fact
that we experience suffering and we
experienced impotence the incapacity to
make things conform to our will to be
better than we would like he says he was
suffering in impotence that created all
after worlds and the brief happiness of
mat breathe madness of happiness that
only the greatest sufferer experiences
so if this is the case then Plato's
ideal world of the forms the Jewish and
Christian and other notions of a
paradise or you know heaven or whatever
you're going to define it as placed
without suffering a place without death
a place where we all get to see each
other again all of those would be
projections that allow people to deal
with how crappy their existence
currently is in this life but they would
all be false
so he says weariness which wants to
reach the ultimate with a single leap
with a death leap a poor ignorant
weariness which no longer wants even to
want that created all gods and all
afterworlds and that's a very
interesting way to frame it isn't it no
longer
wants even to want it wants to not
desire because desiring makes us unhappy
because then we don't get what we want
oh if we could only just stop this
process if there were only a world in
which we would be totally satisfied or
we wouldn't even need to be satisfied
because we wouldn't desire anything
anymore we would be caught in this
eternal perfect whatever it happens to
be harmony you know account of how
everything worked out in the end pick
whatever sort of afterlife you want
nature would say well that's really just
a projection then it comes out of
weakness that comes out of despair comes
out of suffering it's not a positive
thing although it seems like it's super
positive it's actually a negation of a
negation you might say how does this
happen well in Nietzsche's ontology his
view on what actually exists we have
bodies and the body spirit if there is
spirit comes out of the body the body
there's something wrong with it
as he says it was the body that
despaired of the body that touched the
ultimate walls with the fingers of its
diluted spirit it was the body that the
spirit of the earth that heard the belly
of being speak to it and then it created
all of these you know fanciful after
life after worlds something beyond this
so it's really the body in a form of
degeneracy that creates something beyond
the body beyond the earth beyond this
finite existence that we have right here
and it does so in order to deal with the
meaninglessness and the suffering and
the weariness that comes with being a
living thing so that's his explanation
for all of these sorts of pathologies
and after lives now he says that this
isn't the only way that we can think of
things he talks then about the ego the
he says this ego with its contradiction
and its confusion it speaks more
honestly of its being this creating
wheeling evaluating ego which is the
measure and value of things that is what
what we are if we choose to be that if
we choose not to buy into some
pie-in-the-sky it's got all going to be
better sometime down the line if we just
you know don't let ourselves get to down
by how crappy things are here nietzsche
saying don't don't buy into that instead
be this ego he says this most honest
being the ego it speaks to the body it
insists upon the body and it also
insists upon the earth says even more
honestly it learns to speak the more it
learns the more it finds titles and
honors for the body and the earth and
this taught him she says a new pride no
longer bury your head in the stand of
heavenly things but carry it freely an
earthly head which creates meaning for
the earth and so what is he advocating
here don't allow suffering to get you to
project some after.look world or
afterlife or you know transcendent god
out there who's going to be somehow the
solution to all your problems
stick with the world that you actually
have stick with the body that you have
with all of its problems and the fact
that it's going to break down and no
longer work the way you want it to after
a while stick with the earth with this
finite world of existence
he says I teach mankind a new will to
desire this path that men have followed
blindly and Kollek good and no longer to
creep aside from it who who was the the
ones who turned away from this he says
the sick and the dying they despised the
body they invented things of heaven and
redeeming drops of blood but all of this
was actually coming from the body and
the earth which means that the body and
the earth are actually much more than
these after world's men take them to be
they said will the body and the earth
that's not really important stuff maybe
they're even a loser
their material this stuff over here
whatever it is that we're saying is the
transcendent that's where the real
action lies Nietzsche is saying no no no
no no the only way you've got this
transcendent thing over here is that
came out of the body and the earth and
you used its resources to generate it in
the very first place so why not just go
back directly to the body and the earth
embrace the suffering that you have but
don't allow it to drag you down and
don't allow it to turn you into one of
these after worlds Minh
you